uh it turns out that nuclear is one of
the safest things ever uh it's it's it's
a little bit like with airplane crashes
uh actually it's incredibly safe to fly
but every time there is a crash you will
hear about it great analogy so it's it's
a a little bit the same way with you
know Chernobyl obviously was a terrible
disaster uh but you know uh 10 years
later the EU the World Health
Organization the international uh
nuclear commission and several other
organizations went together and said how
many people actually died from this and
they find that it's much less than 2 000
people you know remember this is in a
world where coal Firepower which emits
lots and lots of air pollution will
routinely kill about half a million
people every year